[Applause]
this is the rowdiest audience we've ever
had and that's good
[Applause]
so you've got a reality show you've got
a movie coming out
tell us about that but I have the bigger
question for me is when is the next
fight I'm hoping you know end of summer
I hope we're working towards
well I I always train like yourself I
train every day but you know I was
filming the show yeah and I've got a
couple of commitments with this as well
this this tour around St Patrick's week
but when this commands or when this
finishes it will be you know isolation
I'll go in I'll formulate my camp and
I'll go from Stuart Floyd Mayweather and
let me tell you 90 of his skill he put
behind his back now I'd like to see
Mayweather getting the Octagon yeah and
yes let him fight that way yeah that was
the original you know it was it was a
verbal agreement I box him he fights me
but you know
he bailed it he didn't honor it he
didn't honor it yet you know who knows I
mean you know he's still doing so he
said you go against him in another
boxing belt I'd like another crack I
want you to because I had his ass in the
Octagon yeah
yeah I could always I could always just
you know say it's gonna be a boxing
fight and then just bend them a little
bit when we're in there
but I'm taught about that for mixed
martial artists to give up 90 of your
weapons it's like oh are you serious all
right so you got a movie coming out can
you tell us about it yeah I got a movie
coming out where I'm shooting I'm
shooting a reimagination of the cult
classic Roadhouse
the one with Patrick swayzen the one
with Patrick Swayze is about doing a
version of that I'm doing a version of
it so it's a reimagination of it and it
stars myself Jake Gyllenhaal and uh
Daniela melchior and it was a great
experience had a great time Jake's a
phenomenal actor I learned some great
things from here when you make out in
those scenes that's not real you don't
have no feelings I I just had that I
wasn't making out in this movie or it
was actually like I was cleaning out I
was cleaning out so I I don't by the way
there's the enforcer right yeah yeah uh
now what about this you have Netflix and
a reality show what do you got there
yeah so yeah I'll have a documentary
coming out on Netflix as a four-part
series basically it's been following
following my life I had I had one
previous before it was on Netflix also
and now we've got a fresh one coming out
so it's basically detailing you know the
fight career behind the scenes all the
training my family life and people don't
really have a clue how hard you train
how when you're in training you know
this will certainly this will certainly
shine a light on my tape training you
can start
this is from years ago I don't know if
they're playing it or not yeah uh well
anyway look I've been a fan ever since
by the way my buddy Mark Levin on the
channel he wrote me he's a fan he got me
into MMA right yeah how long ago is this
now oh it's from day one day one yeah
I'm great anyway thank you both thanks
for your great time
we have a big announcement straight
ahead
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else